this morning writer salman rushdie whose
work has made him the subject of death
threats is hospitalized with serious
injuries and is on a ventilator we're
told after he was beaten and viciously
stabbed several times
the brazen attack happened friday in
front of a crowd at a literary event 70
miles southwest of buffalo
nikki batiste reports
this was the scene shortly before 11 a.m
right after the moment a man was tackled
after allegedly stabbing salman rushdie
on stage just as he was about to speak
in chautauqua new york stephen davies
witnessed the attack they got maybe 10
seconds into their introduction when an
assailant
jumped out of the audience onto the
stage he had a black mask and
immediately began pummeling salman
rushdie seventy-five-year-old rusty was
apparently stabbed in the neck and
abdomen a number of people rushed to his
aid the award-winning author was
medevaced to an area hospital did the
attacker say anything not that i heard
rushdie's writings are considered by
many muslims to be blasphemous his 1988
novel satanic verses led to the supreme
leader of iran calling for his execution
rushdie was living with a bounty on his
head now worth over 3 million dollars
you have to defend
things you don't agree with otherwise
what is free speech if it's only for
people that you sort of agree with
police say they are working with the fbi
on the investigation the suspect seen
here was identified as 24 year old haiti
matar from new jersey he had a pass to
access the grounds just the way any
other patron would have
the interviewer who was on stage with
rushdie has minor facial injuries
authorities would not comment on a
possible motive and say they are working
to confirm the suspect acted alone for
cbs saturday morning nikki batiste new
york